[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend uns allen wird künftig
ein Unternehmen gehören quasi als
Miteigentümer über das die meisten von
uns vor kurzem noch kaum etwas wussten
es ist das kann man so sagen
Deutschlands teuerstes Unternehmen denn
es verbrennt jeden Tag Unsummen an Geld
die es nicht hat das Geld kommt jetzt
von uns den Steuerzahlern es sind
bereits jetzt viele Milliarden es werden
aus der umstrittenen gasumlage noch sehr
sehr sehr viele Milliarden mehr werden
da kann einem schwindelig werden aber so
sagt die Regierung das Unternehmen ist
systemrelevant gehe es Bankrott sei die
gesamte deutsche Energieversorgung in
Gefahr ich spreche gleich mit dem
Vorstandschef von uniper der Name ist
übrigens ein Kunstwort abgeleitet aus
unique sind Performance und unique
Performance passt wenn auch komplett
anders als sich das die Marketing Leute
mal gedacht hatten Thaddäus Parade
die Juniper Firmenzentrale in Düsseldorf
keine protz-architektur aber eine mit
Strahlkraft innovativ und finanzkräftig
diese Botschaft steckt wohl dahinter
mehr Schein als Sein
Juniper steckt tief in den roten Zahlen
doch warum dazu einen Blick zurück denn
Juniper wurde 2016 vom Energieversorger
Eon abgespalten damals wurden
Unternehmen aufgespalten man hat so die
Geschäftsfelder die spannend waren in
ein Paket zusammengefasst und alle
Geschäftsfelder die nicht so aufregend
waren wo man keine Zukunft gesehen hat
in ein anderes Geschäftsfeld das wurde
dann die uniper und das entsprechend
verkauft hinter Juniper steckt ein
riesen Konzern weltweit präsent in 40
Ländern mit rund 11.500 Beschäftigten
5000 davon allein in Deutschland zu den
Geschäftsfeldern gehören neben Kohle und
Gaskraftwerken auch Kernkraft
Wasserkraft und Gasspeicher
Hauptmärkte sind Deutschland
Großbritannien Schweden und bis zum
Krieg in der Ukraine auch Russland
Russland gehörte schon bei E.ON vormals
Ruhrgas zu den wichtigsten
geschäftspartnernogas ist traditionell
über Jahrzehnte hinweg einer der
Hauptlieferanten von russischem Gas nach
Deutschland gewesen übrigens auch schon
zu Zeiten vor der deutschen
Wiedervereinigung und war damals selbst
in den schlimmsten Zeiten des Kalten
Krieges ein sehr verlässlicher Lieferant
von Gas ein äußerst lukratives über
Jahrzehnte gewachsenes Geschäftsmodell
das uniper nur allzu gerne weiterführte
und dabei kräftig abkassierte kein
anderer Konzern hat so bedingungslos auf
Russland gesetzt allen Warnungen zum
Trotz auch der alte Kundenstamm spielte
uniper in die Karten mehr als 100
Stadtwerke und Industrieunternehmen mit
langfrist Lieferverträgen somit ist
Juniper Deutschlands wichtigster und
größter Gasversorger der mit Mill in
Summen aus Steuergeld vor der Pleite
gerettet werden muss und wie die Zukunft
aussieht ist völlig offen denn der
Konzern gehört mehrheitlich dem
finnischen staatlich dominierten
Energieversorger Fortum Fortum aber will
kein Geld mehr zuschießen jetzt plant
der Bund sich mit 30% am Unternehmen zu
beteiligen die Juniper Belegschaft aber
ist misstrauisch fordert gar eine
Mehrheitsbeteiligung in einem Brief an
den Bundeswirtschaftsminister warnen die
mitarbeiter:innen ausdrücklich davor
Zitat dass die Interessen von vortum
nicht deckungsgleich mit denen der
Bundesregierung sein werden
100 Millionen Euro Verlust pro Tag
beziffert das Unternehmen und das Geld
aus der gasumlage das uniper beantragt
hat wird erst ab Oktober fließen gut
möglich dass der Konzern bis dahin noch
weitere Milliardenhilfen nötig hat
der Vorstandsvorsitzende von Juniper ist
bei uns Klaus Dieter Maubach Herr
Maubach guten Abend guten Abend der
wichtigste Gasmann Deutschlands
sozusagen ihre Firma ist in aller Munde
plötzlich sorgt für Krisensitzungen der
Bundesregierung weil sie einfach
Unsummen von Steuergeldern aktuell
verbrennen können Sie denn noch ruhig
schlafen angesichts der Situation
wir wenden in der Tat viel Geld der
Steuerzahler auf sie haben es
angesprochen das ist so aber wir werden
das Geld auf damit wir in dem Geschäft
in dem wir tätig sind unsere
Lieferketten aufrechterhalten können wir
haben viele Stadtwerke als Kunden viele
Großkunden in der Industrie und damit
die weiter mit Gas beliefert werden
können zu den Preisen und mit den Mengen
die Sie bei uns geordert haben müssen
wir dieses Geld aufwenden das sind ja
Summen bei denen einem schwindelig wird
also mir geht es auf jeden Fall so ich
denke ihnen geht es möglicherweise
genauso damit man den Überblick nicht
verliert versuchen wir doch mal einen
Preisschild vielleicht drauf zu machen
sie bekamen Mitte August fünf Milliarden
vom Staat aus einer Kreditlinie zwei
Wochen später waren die Weg jetzt haben
sie die Kreditlinie von 9 Milliarden
insgesamt ausgeschöpft und wollen
weitere 4 Milliarden neu dazu haben wie
lange wird das denn reichen
ich hoffe dass uns das die Brücke baut
in den nächsten Winter in der Tat sind
es astronomisch ursummen es ist
allerdings auch so dass wir an den
Märkten
Explosionen der Energiepreise erleben
dass eine große Belastung für unsere
Industrie aber am Ende auch eine große
Belastung für unsere Kunden für
Industriekunden ich sage das schon immer
für alle anderen Kunden es kommt ja auch
eine große Preiswelle auf uns zu
insofern sind das
Preiserhöhungen die wir sich hier
indirekt wenn Sie so wollen schon
ankündigen das bringt sie über den
Winter aber doch nur wenn auch noch die
gasumlage die in den Zahlen die ich
gerade genannt habe noch gar nicht drin
ist dazu kommt die soll aktuell etwa 34
Milliarden bringen zwei Drittel davon
allein an Ihr Unternehmen
ist denn jetzt eigentlich schon klar
dass auch das nicht reichen wird
darf man sagen die gasumlage dient der
Versorgungssicherheit sie dient der
sicheren Versorgung mit Gas an die
Kunden an die Menschen in unserem Lande
an Privatkunden aber auch an
weiterverteilende Unternehmen die wir
insbesondere beliefern insofern ist es
ein Instrument dass es eben nicht kalt
wird in den Wohnungen und Häusern klar
Menschen das haben wir verstanden haben
aber angesichts der Situation in der sie
im Moment Gelder verbrennen ist doch
jetzt bereits absehbar dass auch diese
gasumlage die ja aktuell bereits
umstritten ist wie Sie wissen auch noch
mal erhöht werden muss oder
naja das wird sich zeigen ob sie
wirklich erhöht werden muss es hängt ja
ab von den Preisen an den Märkten in dem
Fall an den Gasmärkten das ist nicht
sicher dass sie erhöht werden muss das
kann sein wie gesagt wenn diese sehr
sehr hohen Preisniveaus die wir derzeit
erleben sich fortsetzen gibt es eine
gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie
erhöht werden muss aber es gibt auch
gute Signale was die Gasmärkte angeht
z.B die Tatsache dass wir unsere
Gasspeicher schon relativ gut gefüllt
haben ihr Mutterkonzern ist ein
finnischer Energie Multi dessen Geschäft
also dessen reines Mutterkonzern
Geschäft sozusagen das läuft noch mit
Gewinn aktuell wie fühlt sich das denn
an wenn man von der Mutter allein
gelassen wird
wir werden nicht von der Mutter allein
gelassen unser großer Aktionär die
finnische Ford um hat uns über die Maßen
finanziell unterstützt es ist nur jetzt
so dass deren finanziellen Möglichkeiten
erschöpft sind und das ist der Grund
warum wir uns Staatshilfe gebeten haben
im Sommer diesen Jahres aber davon zu
sprechen dass wir dort im Stich gelassen
erworben sind das ist nicht richtig naja
alles was man aus Helsinki hört das ist
so eine Art rette sich wer kann Stimmung
die wollen zumindest hört man das
Juniper am besten gestern als heute
abstoßen und loswerden
habe ich nicht ich glaube wir arbeiten
nach wie vor gut zusammen in der Tat
brauchen wir jetzt für das Rettungspaket
bei uniper nicht und die Bundesregierung
wir brauchen auch Ford um fortzum ist
bei uns 80%iger Aktionär ohne Zustimmung
von Ford und wird es eine solches
Rettungspaket nicht geben und alle drei
Parteien arbeiten gut zusammen um dieses
Rettungspaket auf die Beine zu stellen
sie als Zwischenhändler für russisches
Gas also quasi zwischen Gazprom auf der
einen Seite und etwa den Stadtwerken als
Abnehmer auf der anderen Seite in
Deutschland ist denn dieses
Geschäftsmodell überhaupt noch haltbar
welche Zukunft hat denn Juniper anders
gefragt jenseits der Staatshilfe
überhaupt noch
die Tatsache dass Gazprom die Verträge
die wir geschlossen haben nicht einhält
bedeutet nicht dass das Geschäftsmodell
nicht funktioniert wir sind ja nicht nur
mit Gazprom vertraglich verbunden wir
haben auch viele andere Lieferverträge
verkaufen Gas in Aserbaidschan wir
kaufen Gas in den Niederlanden wir
kaufen als größter Händler von
verflüssigem Erdgas in Deutschland
weltweit verflüssigtes Erdgas einbringen
es nach Europa auch in andere Teile der
Welt also dieses Geschäftsmodell das
funktioniert schon noch sehr gut es ist
so wie der Kanzler sagte wir haben eine
Zeitenwende durch den Ukraine Krieg und
das bedeutet eben für uns auch eine
Zeitenwende in der Lieferbeziehung mit
Gazprom Gazprom hat seine Verträge mit
uns gebrochen und das bringt uns in
diese schwierige Lage ja und was dazu
kommt Herr Morbach sie stellen sich
jetzt als ein Unternehmen da das sehr
stark auf andere Technologien setzt und
weltweit guter Letzt ist aber sie sind
mit Abstand der größte Abnehmer von
russischem Gas gewesen haben mehr als
alle anderen gasimporteure auf eben
russisches Gasgesetz all die Jahre durch
sie waren auch in enger weiß ich nicht
enger Vertrauter zumindest haben sie in
direkten Draht gehabt zum
gazprom-chef selbst haben sie von dem
eigentlich mal was gehört
natürlich ist es so dass wir als großer
Kunde von Gazprom regelmäßigen Kontakt
hatten muss ich heute sagen mit der
gazpromenführung da geht es um
Preisverhandlungen und wichtige Fragen
der Verträge wir haben auch vor den die
Verkürzungen miteinander gesprochen
seitdem muss ich sagen gibt es
Funkstille wir haben uns mehrfach an
Gazprom gewendet und deutlich gemacht
dass wir erwarten dass unsere
Lieferungen zu den gazpromenvertraglich
verpflichtet sind wieder aufgenommen
werden das ist nicht geschehen deswegen
müssen wir alle Möglichkeiten jetzt in
Betracht ziehen und vorangehen um zu
unserem vertraglichen Recht zu kommen
was ist das für ein Gefühl ganz
persönlicher Morbach sie bekommen
weniger Gas als zugesagt von Gazprom und
müssen gleichzeitig an dieselbe Gazprom
Mondpreise bezahlen
naja wir bezahlen natürlich nur die
Mengen die wir auch geliefert aber zu
natürlich irren aufgeblähten Gaspreisen
das ist wahr das sind sehr sehr hohe
Preise sie haben sich in der letzten
zwei Jahren
verzwanzigfacht vor 20-facht das ist
eine ihrer Preissprung und es ist
natürlich so dass diese Verteuerung
durch die Verknappung entstanden ist
durch die Verknappung von russischen
Erdgas nach Deutschland es ist für uns
bei uniper eine Enttäuschung dass wir
unsere Lieferbeziehung mit Gazprom nach
mehr als 50 Jahren in diesem Zustand
sehen aber es ist ein Ergebnis des
Krieges den Russland begonnen hat als
Russland die Ukraine überfallen hat du
hast Dieter Maubach war das der
Vorstandsvorsitzende von Juniper Herr
Morbach vielen Dank für das Gespräch
gerne
vielen Dank
und das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen heute Nachmittag aufgezeichnet
und wenn es noch eines weiteren Beweises
bedürft hätte wie sehr bzw wie wenig man
sich auf russisches Gas noch verlassen
kann heute abend kündigt Gazprom an die
Pipeline Nord Stream 1 könne weiterhin
kein Gas liefern Grund sei ein kleines
Öl Leck wie lange der neue Lieferstopp
dauern werde steht in der Mitteilung
nicht
politisch tief gespalten sind die USA
das ist jetzt nichts Neues auch Sorgen
um die amerikanische Demokratie machen
sich ja Beobachter schon länger aber
jetzt kommt eine aufsehenerregende
Warnung vom Präsidenten selbst die
gleichzeitig eine Attacke ist auf seinen
Vorgänger Hannah ja mit Blick auf die
Kongresswahlen im November hat
US-Präsident beiden seinen Vorgänger
Trump in einer Rede scharf angegriffen
und gewarnt dass die amerikanische
Demokratie in Gefahr sei Trump und seine
Anhänger stünden für einen Extremismus
der die Grundfeste der USA bedrohen
würde sie wollten das Land zurück in die
Vergangenheit führen in einer Amerika
ohne Recht auf Abtreibung Privatsphäre
oder Verhütungsmittel beiden sprach auf
einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung in
Philadelphia bei den anstehenden
Kongresswahlen könnten die Demokraten
ihre Mehrheit verlieren
Lufthansa Passagiere mussten heute
wieder mal starke Nerven haben wegen des
ganztägigen Streiks der Pilotinnen und
Piloten sind mehr als 800 Flüge
ausgefallen und 130.000 Passagiere waren
davon betroffen und die Schlangen an den
umbuchungsschaltern entsprechend lang
die Vereinigung Cockpit fordert 5,5%
mehr Lohn und einen Inflationsausgleich
von
8,2%. die Lufthansa bietet den Piloten
dagegen monatlich pauschal 900 Euro für
eineinhalb Jahre
olexie magayev soll neuer ukrainischer
Botschafter in Deutschland werden ein
Sprecher des Auswärtigen Amtes erklärte
das Bundespräsident Steinmeier das
sogenannte agrimon erteilt hätte ein
erster Schritt im
Akkreditierungsverfahren makeef war in
den vergangenen Jahren
Sonderbeauftragter für die
Sanktionspolitik der ukrainischen
Regierung erfolgt auf andre Melnik der
Deutschland im Oktober verlässt
nach dem tödlichen Angriff auf einen
Teilnehmer am Rande des Christopher
Street days in Münster hat die Polizei
einen Verdächtigen festgenommen bei dem
Umzug vergangenen Samstag soll dieser
zunächst mehrere Frauen beschimpft und
bedroht haben als ein 25-jähriger
Transmann schlichten wollte schlug der
Täter ihn unvermittelt zu Boden der Mann
erlag heute morgen seinen Verletzungen
die Militär herunter in Myanmar hat die
ehemalige Regierungschefin und
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin Aaron Sanchi
zu drei weiteren Jahren Haft verurteilt
verbunden mit Zwangsarbeit als Grund
wurde angeblicher Wahlbetrug genannt in
den vergangenen Monaten war die
77-Jährige bereits zu 17 Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt worden die
Verfahren finden unter Ausschluss der
Öffentlichkeit statt zu Chi hatte die
Parlamentswahlen 2020 gewonnen kurz
darauf putschte sich das Militär an die
Macht nach UN-Angaben sind in Myanmar
mehr als 12.000 Bürgerrechtler in Haft
[Musik]
vor zwei Stunden und sicher zurück zu
Hause in Wien hat der Chef der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde eine
erste Bilanz gezogen über die wohl
gefährlichste Reise seines Lebens und
die halbe Welt hängt an seinen Lippen
weil wir alle uns von dieser Mission
mehr Klarheit und Sicherheit erhoffen
denn es geht um ein gewaltiges
Kernkraftwerk das zur Zielscheibe wurde
im russischen Krieg in der Ukraine
Christian Kirsch
als die Inspekteure der
Atomenergiebehörde gestern das
gefährdete Kraftwerk verließen blieb die
Botschaft wir sind gekommen um zu
bleiben
ich habe eben meinen ersten Rundgang
durch zentrale Bereiche hier
abgeschlossen sagte delegationschef
grossi wir haben gesehen was wir hier
zuerst sehen wollten es gibt noch viel
mehr zu tun mein Team arbeitet weiter
und viel wichtiger wir errichten hier
eine ständige Präsenz
zwei Inspekteure der IAEA sollen
dauerhaft bleiben im Kernkraftwerk
saporissia das seit heute wieder in zwei
von sechs Reaktorblöcken Strom
produziert mitten im Kriegsgebiet aus
Moskau hieß es auch heute das Kraftwerk
werde von Ukrainern beschossen
trotz des Besuchs der Spezialisten der
IAA gingen die Provokationen weiter
gestern beschossen ukrainische Truppen
nicht nur das AKW-Gelände sondern auch
die Fahrstrecke der Delegation
was die Ukraine bestreitet
raketeneinschläge seien von Russland zu
verantworten Kiews Forderung das Gelände
zu entmilitarisieren
wir waren mit Herrn grossi und seiner
Mission einig als wir sie trafen dass
das Kernproblem für die Sicherheit der
Anlage darin liegt das Gebiet zu
entmelitarisieren
am Abend dann zurück in Wien zieht der
delegationschef eine erste Bilanz
mai Michael Sören
meine Sorge gilt der Beschaffenheit der
Bausubstanz der Stromversorgung und den
Mitarbeitern der Rest sind Dinge an
denen wir arbeiten können die
strahlungssysteme die
Versorgungssicherheit alles sehr wichtig
aber das ist nicht so dramatisch
das Kernkraftwerk im Kriegsgebiet unter
Beschuss und jetzt auch unter
Beobachtung durch Kontrolleure vor Ort
ja Experte für Atomanlagen russischer
Bauart ist Sebastian stranski von der
Gesellschaft für Reaktorsicherheit die
wird finanziell getragen von der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und den
technischen überwachungsvereinen Herr
stranski schönen guten Abend danke dass
Sie bei uns sind guten Abend sie haben
Direktor grossi gerade gehört was sie da
gehört haben heißt das für sie erstmal
aufatmen ja auf jeden Fall dass seit
einigen Tagen die internationale Atome
Energiebehörde vor Ort ist mit Experten
ist ein sehr sehr gutes Zeichen es war
ja ein Tauziehen über viele Wochen bis
man sich geeinigt hat über welchen Weg
die Experten einreisen können und als
sie am Montag in Wien gestartet sind
haben sie ja ganz kurz ihr Hauptprogramm
veröffentlicht auf Twitter zuerst und
dann über andere Medien und da war
eigentlich schon klar dass er ein
umfangreiches inspektionsprogramm sich
vorgenommen haben und das was ich auch
aus der Pressekonferenz von Herrn grossy
heute abend entnommen habe sie werden
dieses Programm durchziehen und ich
glaube dass am Ende des Tages Ende des
Wochenendes ein erster Eindruck über die
Zeit des Kernkraftwerkes dann durch
unabhängige Experten gewonnen wurde er
hat ja so ein paar Punkte genannt die
ihm aktuell Sorgen machen können Sie das
für uns noch mal genauer erklären bitte
ja er hat ja gesagt der erste Punkt ist
die physikalische oder physische
Integrität des Kraftwerks das heißt dass
die Bauwerke des Kraftwerkes damit sind
natürlich die Sicherheitseinrichtungen
die den Reaktor umschließen aber auch
Nebengebäude wie zum Beispiel die
Gebäude für die Notstromdiesel dass die
heil bleiben dass da nichts passiert das
sämtliche wichtigen Anlagen die für den
Betrieb der Reaktoren oder auch die
nachkühlung der Reaktoren wenn sie
abgeschaltet sind notwendig sind immer
funktionieren der zweite Punkt ist die
Stromanbindung an das ukrainische Netz
oder an die reservestromleitung die für
die Versorgung des Kraftwerks notwendig
sind wenn die Reaktoren nicht laufen
sollten und der dritte Punkt ist das
Personal ich denke das ist auch ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt denn eine der wichtigen
Sicherheit sollen eines sicheren
kraftwerksbetriebes ist dass das
Personal in Ruhe unbeeinflusst und ohne
Druck arbeiten kann und das haben wir
hier schon seit fünf Monaten nicht
wie kann denn jetzt der Besuch dieser
internationalen Experten helfen
er hilft zunächst als erstes erschafft
Öffentlichkeit seit fünf Monaten seitdem
das Kraftwerk russisch besetzt ist vom
russischen Militär kontrolliertes quasi
eine geschlossene Zone ist sind wir
darauf angewiesen was uns die beiden
militärseiten sagen oder die russische
militärseite sagen die einzige
Verbindung zur Öffentlichkeit war die
Telefonverbindung aus dem Kraftwerk
heraus zur ukrainischen Aufsichtsbehörde
oder zum Betreiber in lago-atom wo dann
das Betriebspersonal regelmäßig über den
Stand des Kraftwerkes berichten kann man
muss sich vorstellen dass seit Monaten
kein Mitarbeiter der Aufsichtsbehörde
des Kraftwerksgelände betreten konnte
weder die Inspektoren vor Ort und schon
gar nicht die Leute aus Kiew eigentlich
ein unhaltbarer Zustand den es in der
Form seit der Nutzung der Kernenergie zu
friedlichen Zwecken bisher noch nicht
gegeben hat jetzt sind noch zwei drei so
genau weiß ich das jetzt aktuell nicht
haben sich die Meldung auch so ein
bisschen widersprochen internationale
Beobachter doch noch ein paar Tage
länger vor Ort erhoffen wir uns nicht zu
viel von denen die werden ja diese diese
militärischen Aktionen jetzt alleine
auch nicht aufhalten können soweit ich
weiß sind es fünf es waren ja 14
insgesamt 9 sind heute wieder
zurückgekommen und diese fünf werden auf
jeden Fall bis zum Ende der Mission da
bleiben und aus meiner Sicht sind das
genügend Leute um die Dinge die man sich
angucken sollte sich in Ruhe anzugucken
der Herr Rossi hat heute noch mal
erläutert in der Pressekonferenz am
Flughafen was er im Prinzip für ein
Programm hat das ist aus meiner Sicht
ein sehr sehr gutes Programm und
wirklich nachvollziehbar und umfasst all
das was man sich angucken sollte er hat
ja gestern schon mal in einem
sogenannten ersten Anschauen sich die
wichtigen Punkte angeguckt und hat
gesagt diese Punkte die werden uns jetzt
detaillierter angucken und ich glaube
dass wenn alle diese Punkte angeguckt
sind dann hat man einen guten Überblick
über den Zustand des Kraftwerkes okay
also wir sind auf einem guten Weg in
einer trotzdem natürlich sehr
schwierigen Situation das nehme ich
jetzt aus unserem Gespräche heute Abend
mit Herr stranski herzlichen Dank dafür
danke Sievers
und wir bleiben hier in der Sendung bei
der Energie die die ja diese gesamte
Sendung irgendwie bestimmt wir haben
über das Gas schon gesprochen über
Atomkraft für den Bundeskanzler geht es
heute um Kohle die Energiewende in
Deutschland die ja durch den Krieg in
Teilen schon zur Rolle rückwärts wird
hatte eigentlich eine Kernbotschaft raus
aus dem Klimakiller Kohle die
Ampelkoalition wollte das sogar noch
beschleunigen die betroffenen Regionen
sollen 40 Milliarden Euro als Ausgleich
bekommen eine riesige
Zukunftsinvestition bleibt es bei
alledem heute war Olaf Scholz in der
Lausitz und Stefan Kelch zdf-
der Wandel der Strukturen der Weg weg
von der Kohle dauert immer in der
Lausitz nur sieht man bislang nichts vom
Mantel das irritiert die Menschen
bis jetzt merken wir hier nichts gar
nichts und ich will so nicht ob da noch
was kommt ich glaube das nie also manche
Sachen sind schon
diskussionswürdig wie manche Sachen
angefasst werden was er damit genau
meint will uns Daniel haratz ihn zeigen
er nimmt uns mit auf die sogenannten
hochkippen das ist ein seit den 50ern
mühsam auf Abraum gepäppelter Wald doch
nun sollen hier Solarpaneele und
Windräder hin der Wald muss für
erneuerbare Energie gerodet werden
paradox findet harain
in der heutigen Zeit wo jeder Hektar
Wald zählt
kann das nicht sein dass weil für sowas
zerstört wird wir haben genügend Flächen
wir haben Industriegebiet
in Schleife wir haben andere
landwirtschaftliche Flächen die für
Photovoltaik genutzt werden könnten der
Strukturwandel ein Drahtseilakt die
Lausitzring mit Konzepten mit ihrer
Geschichte Gegenwart und Zukunft vor
allem mit der Zukunft in Weißwasser etwa
da gibt es einen Tümpel der eigentlich
längst der Teich der Zukunft sein sollte
gelegen inmitten eines attraktiven Null
Energie-
wie weit ist es denn mit den
strukturwandelprojekten des Bundes
speziell Infrastruktur speziell die
Verbindung zwischen Berlin und gehört
die Zittau unten die
zweigleisige Ausbau Elektrifizierung
nach unseren Kenntnisstand ist er noch
relativ wenig passiert der Kanzler hat
den kohleministerpräsidenten heute
versichert dass er diese Eisenbahn in
die Oberlausitz bauen wird doch offenbar
muss er dafür auch noch einiges in der
eigenen Regierung bewegen
dass wir verstehen dass
Strukturentwicklung manchmal genau
andersrum geht indem wir eine
Eisenbahnverbindung errichten bestimmte
Infrastrukturen bauen entsteht dass der
Rahmen in dem eine Wirtschaftlichkeit
des Projekts überhaupt erst sich ergeben
kann und noch eine Versicherung wollten
die Azubis des Energiekonzerns leaguag
heute hören kein Kohleausstieg vor 2038
das ist genau unser großer Sorge dass
man aus Berlin heraus immer propagiert
idealerweise 2030 Kohleausstieg aber was
die Umsetzung des Strukturwandels
betrifft immer meilenweit hinterher auf
ein konkretes Ausstiegsdatum wollte sich
der Bundeskanzler jedoch nicht festlegen
lassen
und wir bleiben immer noch beim Thema
Energie das heute wirklich viele
Schlagzeilen macht jetzt auch bei Diana
ja Christian denn noch immer verdient
Russland Milliarden mit dem Export von
Öl trotz westlicher Sanktionen jetzt
wollen die G7 Staaten einen Ölpreis
Deckel einführen um genau das zu
verhindern Stefanie Barrett an der
Frankfurter Börse wie soll das genau
funktionieren ja die G7 Staaten Streben
tatsächlich eine breite internationale
in Allianz an eine Art käuferkartell das
einen globalen preisdeckel auf
russisches Öl beschließen soll im
Prinzip will man den Transport
russischen Öls erschweren westliche
Versicherungen und Tanker wären da ein
möglicher Hebel so könnten
Schiffstransporte von ölimporteuren etwa
nur dann versichert werden wenn sie
russisches Öl mit einem Preislimit
transportieren wo das genau liegen
könnte und wann es kommt noch unklar
Russlands Antworter gegen prompt und
unmissverständlich man werde kein
weiteres Öl an Länder liefern die
preisbeschränkungen verhängen
prom hat außerdem am frühen Abend ja
angekündigt die Gaslieferungen durch
nordstream 1 morgen nicht wie geplant
wieder aufzunehmen ob auch das eine
Reaktion auf den G7 Vorschlag ist schwer
zu sagen aber durchaus denkbar denn da
wie China und Indien müssten mitziehen
ist das dann realistisch also selbst G7
vertreterräumen ein dass die großen
ölkunden China und Indien unbedingt an
Bord sein müssen damit das ganze
funktioniert das ist aber sehr
unwahrscheinlich denn China und Indien
dürften nicht nur wegen Russlands
angekündigtem Lieferstopp wenig geneigt
sein diesem käufer-kartell beizutreten
sie haben im Hinblick auf Russland
bekanntlich auch ihre eigene Agenda also
ob hier tatsächlich eine so breite
Allianz geschmiedet werden kann ist
wirklich sehr fraglich und da der Westen
ja seit den Sanktionen ohnehin
russisches Öl meidet wo er nur kann
stellt sich auch die Frage wie ein
starkes käuferkartell tatsächlich zu
Stande kommen soll so ganz ausgegoren
scheint die Pläne also noch nicht zu
sein danke Stefanie für designordnungen
der fünfte Spieltag der Bundesliga hat
heute mit der Partie Borussia Dortmund
gegen die TSG Hoffenheim begonnen die
Dortmunder haben im heimischen Stadion
mit eins zu null gewonnen
der mit einer Million Euro dotierte
körperpreis ist heute dem britischen
Zellbiologen Anthony Heimann vom
Dresdner Max-Planck-Institut für
molekulare Zellbiologie und Genetik
verliehen worden gewürdigt wird seine
Erforschung von zelltröpfchen
sogenannten kondensaten diese können bei
fortgeschrittenem Alter schädliche
Ablagerungen hinterlassen die Einfluss
auf Krankheiten die Alzheimer oder als
haben highmen forscht an neuen
Medikamenten die diese Krankheiten
heilen könnten
wichtiger Preis wichtige Forschung so
Puma Marder und Co den Zustand der
Bundeswehr untersuchen gleich zwei
echte Experten Fabian Köster und Lutz
van der Horst machen den großen bw-check
in einem heute-show Spezial das lohnt
sich sehr gleich nach uns
und unser heute journal Update gibt es
gegen 0 Uhr mit Christopher Wehrmann von
uns allen hier im heute-
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
Abend ja das hoch das bleibt immer noch
fest über Skandinavien und versorgt uns
aus Osten mit trockenerer und kühlerer
Luft das mächtige tief bei irland muss
südwärts ausweichen zapft die warme Luft
von Westen an vorher bringt uns dieses
kleine tief aber noch Schauer und
Gewitter und zwar heute Nacht aus dem
Südwesten kommen die Schauer und
Gewitter voran morgen früh bis zu einer
Linie Eifel Alpenvorland morgen über Tag
breiten sich die shower und Gewitter
weiter aus erfassen dann auch
Nordrhein-Westfalen bis Bayern abends
vereinzelt auch das Erzgebirge diese
Gewitter können örtlich kräftigen
Starkregen bringen größtenteils können
wir uns wohl aber einfach überreden
freuen das gilt jedoch nicht für den
Nordosten des Landes schon heute Nacht
in der es auf 16 bis teils nur sechs
Grad abkühlt ist es hier trocken und oft
klar und auch morgen haben wir hier
einen trockenen Sonne wolken-mix denn
dieser frische Ostwind bringt eben die
trockene kontinental Luft und die hält
gegen diese instabile feuchte Luft aus
Südwesten am meisten Sonne sehen wir
morgen Richtung Niedersachsen deswegen
auch hier bis zum Niederrhein
sommerliche 25 bis 27 Grad sonst 20 bis
24 Grad und in den nächsten Tagen geht
es warm am Montag im Westen sogar
hochsommerlich weiter dazu haben wir
ruhiges Wetter und nur vereinzelt
Schauer und Gewitter das allerdings
ändert sich ab Dienstag dann steigt die
Regenwahrscheinlichkeit an und es wird
auch so langsam wieder kühler tschüss